you
[Music]
it's all about love Nick Cannon is
definitely feeling the love these days
during an appearance on Thursday style
code live the Entertainer got candid
about his ex Mariah Carey and how they
co-parent their five-year-old twins
Moroccan in Monroe when you put the kids
first but then when you understand that
you have unconditional love for these
human beings and you want the best
existence for them then you click
whatever differences you may have had
aside and if you can remove your ego
from that and make it about your loved
ones in a specific hashtag lovey
Gannon and Kari are such friendly exes
the comedian said he's even open to
collaborating with her on new music we
have done stuff before in the past
hey you never know it could happen again
Canon also opened up about this photo he
shared in December the 36 year old spent
Christmas in the hospital dealing with
lupus I had too much medicine in me and
I had to have like five blood
transfusions cuz like it was so much
stuff I'm good now
[Music]
you